yesterday New York Post Hillary Clinton
Democrats are preparing her to run I
don't know if you saw that article did
you see that yeah I'm curious to know
good pull it up let's let's read it and
uh uh did you see this or no Adam I have
not Adam okay go there you go press Ctrl
plus to make it a little bigger Hillary
Clinton versus Donald Trump 2024 yep
life has become a horror movie
great title go well all right so we are
officially a horror movie where the
monsters Never Dies the virus never ends
in the next election sees Hillary
Clinton versus Donald Trump yes the two
most polarizing presidential nominees of
the modern time refused to go away
Clinton and Trump are more likely than
they realize namely they each live in a
reality of their own making Trump
continues to insist that Tony Tony
election was stolen Hillary but he said
she won in 2016. what I was doing was
working she told New York Magazine 2017
of Bernie Sanders Donald Trump said I
beat both of them back then I called
Hillary Norma Desmond of American
politics ever ready for her close-up
while knuckle link or grip on a scene
that uh long ago rejected her as she
refused to rule out 2020 Party leaders
were vocal about moving on Joe Biden I
never thought she was a great candidate
Chuck Schumer when you lose to someone
who has 40 popularity you don't blame
other things you blame yourself wow so
so so this is this is pretty interesting
do you think this is a real story or do
you think this is just kind of like New
York Post wanted to write a story so
people will talk about but she's not
going to be running you know I wouldn't
put it past her she's so tone deaf that
it wouldn't surprise me Not only would
it not surprise me if she ran again but
it wouldn't surprise me if she ran again
and did the exact same stuff she did you
know multiple other times skipped States
just you know was totally you know not
paying attention to the actual issues
that people care about that would be a
great movie The problem is like we're in
pretty distressed times right now like I
mean look I I the person I think should
run for I want to see Ron DeSantis up
there I really do
um I think he's done an amazing job and
I think he takes no garbage and he holds
media accountable but he also like knows
when to get out of his own way the
problem with Trump and you know I took
polenti of heat for criticizing Trump
and it wasn't policy that I was
criticizing
you made a comment about how he was
concerned I was tired of all of it I was
just he couldn't get out of his own way
often times and you told him a third
grader yeah because you know the name
calling and all of that stuff it was
just you know it's funny sometimes and
you know it revs up the bass and if
you're going to a rally it can be like
oh haha Trump made a joke but
you know the bottom line was if he would
have just stepped back and let his
record speak for itself and just know
when to just pivot away it's not about
you it's not about a petty battle on
Twitter that kind of drove me nuts after
a while so my issue wasn't with policy
on him it was with character and just
like come on man just step away and let
let these these successes be successes
so DeSantis you know I like governors in
these positions because they've actually
run something and I really like him I've
seen many interviews where he's just
like that's not what's happening you
know these are the facts this is what
we're doing in Florida this is the model
for a free nation and a free Society so
um that's what I'm a fan of and listen I
always welcome Hillary Clinton Ron it's
a guaranteed disaster
is a disaster but you're saying no
chance she runs wait wait did you just
say no chance tone deaf as she is really
to remix
you think that you think the Democratic
party wants her back no you think
there's you know fervor for her Joe
Biden is
clearly the Democrats need to figure out
who's in their stable clearly we talked
about Michelle Obama potentially being a
candidate I've I've never thought that
she was going to run ever and now I'm
like well you know if there's ever a
time in trouble I think she runs she
could win I don't again same thing I
don't think she wants to give up that
life would you vote for Trump in 2024
against two
yeah or anyone anyone anyone whoever the
Democrats throw up there I will never I
will never vote for a big government
Democrat ever I will never vote for big
government so my problem with Trump you
know I have to listen to what Trump says
and Trump we already know what he's
going to say so yeah and now he's on the
vaccine's odd comments and this that and
I think what I will say is today and I
can't tell you what I'm gonna do next
round I know I often do a lot of
write-ins because I'm like oh these
people all are just terrible but I can't
tell you what I'm gonna do today because
I don't know in that situation but my my
guy is DeSantis okay
and his wife has health issues that he's
dealing with right now and he's
attending to right now so if you enjoy
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]